it has long been the word online that
Wesley Snipes wasn't the easiest to work
with on the set of Blade Trinity the
actor supposedly remained in his trailer
for most of the shoot emerging only to
film close-ups thus leaving his
stand-ins to do the bulk of the work
over the years other stories like him
only communicating with director David S
goyer solely through Post-it notes
attempting to choke him out at one point
and refusing to open his eyes for one
scene have gained a lot of traction on
the internet give he would communicate
with with uh Post-its that he would give
to the director and each one he would
sign blade his interactions with Ryan
Reynolds have also made the rounds
somewhat explaining Reynolds disinterest
in working with Snipes again
unsurprisingly as the many blade Trinity
rumors centered on him have picked up
steam Wesley Snipes has taken it upon
himself to set the record straight in
some regards when it comes to his
Post-It note usage long trips to his
trailer and clashes with David S goyer
these points stemming from comedian and
Blade Trinity actor Pat Oswalt he
asserted during a chat with the guardian
that these supposed anecdotes from the
set Are Nothing More Than Fiction